E aí
[Aplausos]
Oi bom dia tá
E mais uma vez a Muito obrigado a todos
e para você presidência como disso
o legal foi mãe
e até uma disseram que tinha que ser
aliciante resiliência estou de acordo
com a perna e a uma descrição bem claro
perfeita para o povo ver é o meu muito
obrigado por jogar nos adoro e as
pessoas todos e os autores envolvidos os
técnicos não foi fácil não foi fácil e
até agora mas estamos tudo Parabéns já
está ali é esse a parte da livraria
tinha hábito de motivo para desistir mas
estamos aqui e continuamos a acreditar
do melhor para viver
o clima quando me convidou falou sobre o
evento lyrics ideia foi uma surpresa de
repente a gente já se conhece há
bastante tempo ou na na área logística e
ele começou e eu vi isso a mão desafio
mas o tempo eu tinha que ser junto
aliado na no evento salgada vieram minha
perna que diz
e como sobreviver depois de chegar
oficialmente desempregado como
sobreviver como empreendedor
e como empreendedor e pronto já era uma
um evento que tava dizer inicialmente
era Internacional e estava feita vai ser
feito todos os ensaios em Legião que
desde do português e fica Vamos decidir
que vamos começar essa parte porque
depois passar para outro
e já agora e vamos começar
necessariamente o ponto crucial como
empreendedora principalmente na onde nós
estamos onde nós colocamos em África
onde nós colocamos e Moçambique e
desafio hoje são maior são muito vai
chegar um saber
e o pyrotic pirata vol centro de
referência não é o melhor
e o motorista que está a conduzir o
carro na linha reta não acaba tendo
muito bom motorista e as escovas de
filhas supridas o perigo percurso faz o
melhor motorista está para contar a
história
e eu vou cortar o imprevisto e como
sobreviver oficialmente de Brigado e
você enfrentar
E aí certo o que não está certo dizer
quem te paga celular quem te paga
despesa quem vai pagar a escola quem vai
pagar maquiagem da esposa etc etc mas
você é possível perceber que a
responsabilidade de suas ações são a sua
casa nas casas de familiares que você
tem como os colaboradores negócio estão
a trabalhar juntas tanto a
responsabilidade e quase publicado de
Obrigado por aí vocês até o
responsabilidade já não é mais sobre ti
mas os outros
o que não é só a sua família mais
exótico tanto como sobreviver a mim eu
tenho uma coisa Claro mas muito simples
que é a visão
e se tu tens a visão é a única coisa que
vai te fazer você conseguir sobreviver
e na visão instalar englobar o sonho e
você deve ter um sonho que muito mais
forte e maior de que a ti
se você deve ter um sonho muito mais
maior do que a tia que tu pensas e a
visão que vai séria chave de conduzir
durante o percurso são duas pode ser
chave e são todos encerado com uma coisa
que é a fé ao livro é que o bastante
gosta de ler e ver
bom E se for a very se alguém consegue
ter um tempinho e conseguir ver o que
está no livro de provérbios 29 está lá
tudo se acha que o homem precisa nessa
terra
e se tu és um visionário já Consegues
ver já consegue ver algo que não existe
e se tu és um visionário você consegue
viver alguma coisa 15 anos ser vivo um
as pessoas mas tu viste anos é isso que
vai fazer você será motivar o dia por
dia acordar três quatro madrugada mesmo
que não haja resultado visível para as
pessoas ao redor você vai ser capaz de
continuar em quando todo mundo desistiu
quando todo mundo disseram que está
difícil você sendo visionário já está
claramente certo que eu vou estar em
cima daquele prédio Dentro de 10 15 anos
é importante aqui é que está aqui tablet
não está a ver o que você está conseguir
ver é isso que faz a diferença é isso
que faz você continuar porque carrega
algo muito mais além muito mais
importante é isso que faz você continuar
mesmo se o carro não anda e vais andar
de bicicleta ir o serviço se veste
Monteiro bicicleta faz acordar mais cedo
a pé ir lá onde você sabe que lá
eu admiro 2030 Range Rover Evoque 011
Mas tu estás a ir a pé
Ah e alguém ao lado de ti só porque viu
algum optar não tinha carro com pneu de
adquirir ela desistiu não é o visionário
o visionário isto você que tem um quadro
você que tem o final mais Estúpido do
final a partir do it
se você não está preocupado no que está
aqui curto prazo você está preocupado
com aquilo instalar longo prazo
é a visão é tudo a visão é a chave vai
fazer você dizer sim onde todo mundo
sabe dizer não
é a visão é tudo que vai fazer você
levar o último recurso que você tinha
mais pagar alguém falar e você seja
perca como vou sobreviver para comprar
comida para casa
é porque e a visão que tu tens é muito
mais importante a visão que tu tem é do
grupo das empresas mas olha só apenas
três uma bateria com duas cadeiras
o som
Oi e a pergunta é Qual é o dinheiro que
está a Gerar essa Vacaria
e com duas cadeiras
Ah E ainda por cima você deve sustentar
esse negócio porque não está se a
rentável
é mas se você tem a visão num grupo das
empresas que você já tem a visão E terá
sofá Não este ano indico na beira que o
topo de rei tempo mas começasse sempre
mente com duas cadeiras na esquina onde
está a pagar 50 metros
é mas é que a sua visão é muito mais
grande de que as duas cadeiras visível
neste preciso momento com alguém aluga
um
de sopa de ar
é um palpite tô dizer que não é aves
imaginar e sonhar
e eu sempre tive um sonho é um plano de
ter um sofá quando os homens podia ser
tratado Pode Foi algo que me com papel
Percebi que os homens estão preocupado
em pagar falar umas no fim das contas
não esquecemos Nós também precisamos ter
cuidado pagamos lá um de luz para esposa
Mas esquecemos Nós também precisamos
estar bem apresentar quem é e se
preocupa com os homens e oca peço da
onda uma das pessoas disse vou fazer
tudo para vestir
e numa galeria que vai ser dois milhão
e agora a pergunta é essa luz o mercado
não prometo não tem grande mãe mas eu ia
água além o dinheiro se essas pessoas
neste momento conseguem pagar 50
meticais cinco anos depois já terão uma
vida diferente e vão conseguir pagar 200
metros a estátua você tem que acompanhar
o passo o processo de onde você quer
chegar como você deve saber que não
existe nada mais nada mesmo que grande
início Grande
a alma gay do processo que deve seguir e
aproveita nove meses na barriga da mãe
antes da partida mas a família já tem
alegria a partir do primeiro mês que a
esposa disse para o marido tô grávida é
exatamente assim como funciona EA fé que
existe a fazer essa família ficar feliz
é que acredita que envolve anos depois
nove meses depois a mais um membro da
família
e depois daquela parte continua a festa
há um ano depois curto de uma festa o
somos nós aqui estamos com 40 50 60 anos
aqui você como visionário você como
empreendedor deve saber aqui não tem
como chegar ao Top sei que segue o
processo
é a lei do processo onde deve ser que
não pode escapar não tem como você pisar
um botão para quem está subir elevador
não ai ai
e a um processo no médias processo
artifício em quando mais difícil é maior
é a visão
é o sonho aqui é o DNA por exemplo é ser
a maior empresa né a nível África que
controlar a cor da velha control acordou
da Beira por ali durante lá isso não é
fácil
e é praticamente impossível a amostra é
ali por aí né que atividade 99% de
positividade mesmo se for 0.1 percent to
face The Deep vai ser possível porque
você é a pessoa que está ver o que pode
ver nossa pessoa as outras pessoas que
eu falo Acompanhar até sua própria
esposa ou esposo pode dizer não a visão
que tu tem
e é tão assustador que não é possível
mas você como empreendedor visionário
deve ser capaz de acreditar em sonhos e
se conduziram até o fim
a interação as pessoas ao lado de ti
terás as pessoas que vai se perder no
caminho é normal né
é mas para aprender enfrentar o
habitáculo deve aprender enfrentar o
desafio
é a visão para mim é a chave de tudo que
tu queres como sucesso funciona para o
casamento funciona para o negócio
funciona para que tu queres que consegue
por quê que acontece que ele realiza um
casamento perfeito é um processo bem
É mas tem que saber que não fiz a subo
tão de repente as suas forças é uma
maravilha os seus próximo Afinal a um
processo e deve seguir os processos
nunca pode pensar que você vai sacar um
para chegar um gesto não não
e nós conversar 0134 falar muito das
vezes hoje estamos no mundo de insta
rápido sucesso rápido sucesso não tem
Instagram não lá é um processo que você
deve ter construir bar Lee e
é mas já quem viu visualizou como vai
ser esse preto e as Pilares capilar tem
seu trabalho é
O que é assim que funciona Você
provisionar já viu quantas vezes você já
vão chegar d0s não está provável volta
por mais sapato essa Pilar aqui não vai
se é possível
é aguentar com o ciclone tá tem que
botar você trabalhar com os sapatos que
vão conseguir ciclope
Esse é um processo é um desafio mas você
deve saber quando quero ter sucesso
Beijo abraço beijo abraçada a
e se tu quer ser importante mas quero
diferentes 34 anos atrás eu pesava mais
de 100 un
eu e a Gabi disse não era possível
perder aqueles Mas eu sabia que um dia
já vai estar na terça-feira e vou
precisar ficar bem e como fazer entra eu
ia chegar a visão e desviei havia uma
pessoa quiser acreditar ele é
o último dizer que não faz isso é
possível não tem como repetir destrói
não use isso não vai conseguir quatro
partes mais de 40 anos é possível a
pessoa que acredita nisso é a única
pessoa que é
Oi e o resto é que acompanhada o
funcionário está preparado dormir fora
embaixo de caminhão antes de chegar
entregar chave um tablet novo você vai
nomear e fui comprar o carro observa 1
é o personagem está preparado zero
mordido com todos e pede para poder
conseguir força você como empreendedor é
muito difícil mas vale a pena
E porque é que a obra seja descobri
Quina nesta tudo bilionário que existe
no mundo não existe nenhum alguém
bilionário empregado no vinho do pico
a novix existe um avez errado avô está
completamente o a máfia aqui ó composta
por que isso funciona tão maneira que
Deus criou as coisas o padrão disciplina
sacrifício e benefício próprio tão
simples quanto vai ter surpresso leva o
prêmio no American um arranjo você deve
se refere a um sacrifício para conseguir
a vidão eu já tinha feito esse trabalho
de visão e só para exportar um tempo
muito já tinha feito o trabalho de visão
tem quase 10 dias e aí entra o
O que é isso eu faço inglês a visão sem
fé visualiza
a mulher e John significa André está ali
Tricae
Oi como vai fazer mas e iniciar a
E acredite isso vai levar 50 anos amiga
é que se tu tiras no ônibus 50 Fica 49
e se tu tiveres um ano três da foto não
sou mas tu não tira nem um dia absoluta
certeza que não esquece agora iniciou a
sua preferência
hoje ou vem aqui com optar faz parte do
processo eu falei obstáculos todo mundo
vai quiser dão Mas sexta-feira quem vai
buscar o banco vai ter não Não tem o
processo continua continua até um dia o
a opção estás a terminar Beijo não pode
você só dizer quero pessoas que quer
dizer alguma coisa incrível sonho sou o
bom então para esse fim do produto pode
parecer clima é só o que eu posso fazer
isso é isso é por isso ninguém pode
levar né É se deve trocar a
e esta o cenário aqui eu e você temos
tudo aqui dentro podemos fazer quando
acredito não é tipo assim leva o nosso
possível tem sapato na tarde de hoje o
resultado do trabalho que se a quem fé
foi criado por mesmo tempo porque é que
você não pode
E porque é que você não pode é mais ou
menos podemos dizer mais uma vez muito
obrigado fiquei um bocadinho daquele
visão muito empreendedor cm aqui temos
uma ar aqui temos um